this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you everyone for joining me today
and as an introduction alluded to I'm
going to talk about my experience while
on the drear award and what my main
focus is in giving this talk is less to
kind of walk you through my experience
in a chronological order but more to
share with you some of the experiences
some of the findings and some of the
things that I found to be most
interesting while experiencing the
biodiversity in South Africa so I'm here
in the Horticulture Department and I
spent a number of years working in
horticulture and as a horticulturalist
whenever you come up and you meet a
plant you have to ask it three questions
what is your name where you're from and
how do you get here and this is a great
picture of a ficus macrophylla here in
South Africa this is meaning for scale
standing down here and these are the
kind of questions that I tend to like to
ask plants because they tend to reveal
very interesting stories and when I
asked this question of some of the
plants that I've experienced and seen
throughout visiting guardians or other
places around the world one place kind
of kept coming up time and time again
where you just would find very unusual
and interesting flora and just did
something that was just kind of outside
the realm of what we tend to tend to
typically find so as a lot of people
know here in the Horticulture Department
South African plants have had a large
impact on the horticultural trade and
you may or may not realize this i'm
going to go through me some examples
right here of a bunch of plants that you
may not realize come from south africa
so the xanth indicia the calla lily is a
very common plant that is endemic to
south africa it has been used and
hybridized extensively for all sorts of
ornamental qualities pelargoniums the
flowering geraniums a plant that is
completely ubiquitous in used for
planting and potting beds or as a
popular bedding plant is a genus of
plants that is also comes from south
africa
kniphofia the red-hot poker a very
common ornamental plant that we tend to
find and Mediterranean climates and
subtropical regions is used extensively
also comes from South Africa stirlitz
iya the bird of paradise in a very
interesting genius of plants there's
there's five species that comprise the
the general including some that grows
largest trees but as we can see from
these pictures here also picked up and
used very commonly as guardian plant
ornamentally the protease EA is a big as
a large family of plants but but one of
the very special components of plants
that we kind of see in South Africa a
lot of people when they think about the
Western Cape when they think about fine
boss this is one of the images that
comes to mind this idea this protea this
is this group of plants that is unique
to that region I'll get into some of
these details as we go through the talk
pro diaz are used in as for fresh
flowers there in the flesh flower
industry but they also when you drive
the florets themselves can actually
store quite well and that's what this
picture is illustrated here on the right
our protea heads that have been cut and
our dried and are going to be shipped
all over the world to use for cut flower
displays succulent plant biodiversity
South Africa boasts having roughly
thirty percent of the world's succulent
plant biodiversity and this is we find
this particularly in the northwestern
part of the country where we find all
sorts of interesting things like high
diversity of aloes or many of the plants
in the azo ACA family such as how were
Thea's or plants like conniff items
which are also commonly used where the
culturally people are very interested in
these plants for some of the interesting
adaptations they develop but also
because they're they're fun and they're
interesting there's something different
you like to put them in terrariums and
other such uses such as this
what they're two different Jenna and
then the bulb biodiversity is another
major you know we're getting through a
lot of plants and i hope to exposing
people to the kind of diversity that is
out there but here are just some some
great pictures of the bulb biodiversity
and even here in the Horticulture
Department we focus on some of our labs
focus on growing plants such as the
ornithogalum or as well as the you comas
is another cut flower and also bedding
plant that has also gained worldwide
appeal and use in the horticultural
world and almost through one of the very
interesting things about about South
Africa is known as some of the mass
flowerings up in namaqualand namaqualand
roughly refers to a region that is the
north western part of south africa and
they are known for having these
magnificent displays if they get good
rains in the in the wintertime well when
they get there precipitation and and
this is a phenomenon that's been been
noted for one say since the mid late or
early 1900s and just to kind of point
out what's going on here in particular
this picture on the far right this is a
picture taken at one of the national
botanic gardens that's actually managed
more of a natural area and what you're
looking at here is is you can kind of
see is just the vast diversity of
different bulbs that are that are
blooming and growing in this one set of
land this is a landscape that has been
managed primarily only buy weed removal
and maybe having having grazing that
came in and causes a natural disturbance
and this is a highlight it brings people
to this kind of part of the country
where most people wouldn't go for
tourism otherwise but you contrast this
to the shots here this is a farm that's
also in the namaqualand region but they
annually plow to encourage these
pioneering species like the Earth's
ania's hear that cause this kind of mask
carpet blooming effect as you can see
from the picture it just goes on and on
and so these in these images of the mass
blooms have really captured people's
imaginations this is a picture of one of
the first was actually taken by by Hans
hair
are the first curator at stellenbosch
botanic garden where I was spending my
drear experience and this was one the
first photo color photographs to make it
was a postcard actually in it to make it
to Europe and kind of put this amazing
biological display kind of on the world
stage and you also find some of the the
weird and the wonderful so plants such
as the hidden aura africana here which
is a parasitic plant that grows on you
for be arranged so we're related to eres
tu la key or the Dutchman's pipe that
some people may know as well as
wonderful plants like well which in
mirabilis which is in the natales order
a very fascinating plant it's the only
species and its whole family and this
grows in the northwest region up into
Angola and Namibia in kind of this fog
belt and just a very unusual plant
people have been wonder by it and
interesting Lee enough stellenbosch
Botanic Garden was the first garden two
ever grow this plant from seed and get
it up to a point where it would cone and
set seed once again so through that kind
of display of pictures that i just
showed you i hope to have revealed just
some of the things that really make the
biodiversity of South Africa so
fascinating so interesting and something
that's pretty unusual compared to what
we may see when we walk out of our door
so I think the the natural question that
comes to mind is is why is South Africa
so biologically diverse when it comes to
to that's a vascular plant flora and I'm
showing you an image here of what's
known as a flower show at the flower
show in South Africa and this is
enlarged contrast to what we may
experience if we went to a flower show
maybe like the Philadelphia Flower Show
or a flower on Europe a lot of these
kind of flower shows that we may be used
to or kind of more contrived there their
image we will go and we'll see a plant
but the plant may not be the main
display of the focus their focus of the
display it may be more kind of
ornamental ornate or the scene they
create around it is going to be
something that they kind of focus on in
South Africa there's a number of town
that host these flower
shows and that these flower shows what
farmers and local people in that
community will go out just into their
fields just around the roadsides just
anywhere that surround and and they'll
harvest these massive amounts of just
plants are growing around these weren't
grown ornamentally just for these
displays this is just the natural kind
of abundance that's around and they
bring them and of course putting it
together is kind of contrived in this
kind of context of having so minute so
much with the biodiversity or the plants
themselves stuck together in one place
but I like to share this image just
because it shows both a different
perspective of how South Africans
interact with their flora but also just
the sheer magnitude of the diversity
that's there and these are great
experiences for getting people
interested in horticulture and gardening
but they also have a large educational
component where they actually have
sections where they label all these
plants and you can go and you can kind
of actually learn what's around you as
well so to kind of put South Africa in
context and put the floor there in
context i'm going to start with with
North America place that we're all
familiar with North America excluding
Mexico north of Mexico makes up roughly
fifteen percent of the Earth's surface
and on that fifteen percent of the
Earth's surface we have about six point
two five percent of the world's total
vascular plant biodiversity 20,000
species roughly now we jump to South
Africa and what we're looking at here is
less than one percent of the Earth's
surface so 08 point percent and thirty
thousand individual species so roughly
ten percent of the world's total
biodiversity so as you know a huge
amount of biodiversity and relatively
small space and this distribution is not
even across the whole country there are
certain areas that have more speciation
than others
so to give to continue to give people a
context we're going to work from a large
scale and focus in now there's multiple
ways how people choose to describe the
different plant communities that are
around them and on the biggest scale the
scale we typically look at is known as
floristic kingdoms and floristic
kingdoms describe relationships that are
primarily between family and on the
general level and they focus on three
main different areas they focus on
distribution of these families in
general either being cosmopolitan very
widespread being endemic very narrow
only occurring in a very small amount of
space or having disjunctions large
barriers between different types of
families redwoods are a good example of
that while in China you may have the
dawn redwood metasequoia clip to screw
boy DS while in North America you have
the coastal redwood or the giant redwood
would be an example of distinction and I
want to point out in this picture you
know you can see that the whole Arctic
Kingdom is the largest the one that
we're probably most familiar with here
but if we look down to the tip of Africa
we see that there's one little section
here that stands out in in pink here and
this is known as the kick the Cape
floristic region and the reason why I
show this picture and kind of point this
out is that even on this scale even on
the largest scale of the earth what
we're seeing is that the there's
something going on down there that makes
the flora they're so unique in its
relationships and families in general
that it that it highlights this one
region is the only country in the world
that houses its own floristic Kingdom
it's kind of a big way of looking at
plants so there's some subjective pneus
to it but it's a good a good general
context so now taking it one step down
we step into the levels of biomes and
what biomes primarily describe our
plants based on their structure how do
they overall look and on ecological
factors so the main factors that people
use to describe Flores based on biomes
are going to be minimal winter
temperature seasonality of rainfall and
then summer aridity how drive gets in a
region and these are kind of we'll go
we're going to go into some of these in
just a moment some of the kind of big
landscapes that we may think of
in the northeastern part of the United
States for example we think of our
hardwood forests as being our
predominant biome if we went to the
Midwest we would think of what
historically would be the Great Plains
as being another biome so big kind of
character you know the way the fluorides
grow the way they actually look is the
major kind of driver of this or the way
we describe it and I'm going to go
through a couple here so we're going to
start off with the savanna biome this is
found in the north eastern part of the
country and these are areas that are
tend to be dominated by a lot of grass
and few trees this is the area where
you'll find beginning of the Bayeux babb
trees that will continue some of the
world's most widest trees that you find
that will continue up into subtropical
tropical Africa and these are the
landscapes that support the large
mammals and that that are major drivers
of the ecology and this land landscape
here the next kind of biome we stepped
into a very big one now is the forest
biome the forest biome is a very
interesting by them it's it's the
smallest I think it's less than a
percent of the total biomes and that map
I showed you before you didn't even
notice it because we're so small and
this biome is very interesting because
it is a biome that receives most of the
most of the the biomes are in South
Africa are dictated by summer rain fall
or winter rainfall and that is a major
definer of the kind of plants to tend to
grow in these areas in the forest biomes
they receive rainfall all year round and
that is because they are on just along
the south coast of South Africa and
what's interesting about this biome is
it's very very concentrated and
unfortunately with the lights it's hard
to make this out what's what's
interesting about this picture here is
saying it's a very kind of Kemp
compressed where these forests actually
grow so this is along the south coast as
you kind of going north here and pretty
much where this picture cuts off right
here you end up in fine boss by them so
it goes from kind of shrubby grasslands
and then you come in down here and
you're in this forested area and you can
actually see this contrast right here
this little bit here is actually fine
boss and then and then forest
immediately starts off these cliffs so
it's a relatively small biome but a very
interesting one it's where we tend to
find obviously the big trees things like
the
put ur called podocarpus focus or the
yellow wood which are some of their
giant trees photo carps are an
interesting some interesting lineages
and themselves having relations to flora
in australia or new zealand and some
large destructions there i put this
other picture up of track of
colitiscolitis it's related to the witch
hazel family which we may know from our
local flora here and kind of one of the
few that is that is present both in in
our flora as well as south africa's
another major biome is the kuru biome
and this is the kind of areas that
support a lot of this really interesting
succulent plant biodiversity they tend
to get winter rainfall and have a lot of
these interesting succulent
characteristics cam adaptation and do
interesting things like like grow as you
can see in this picture here they're
little kind of items that are just as
eking out an existence just between
these rocks or they're not going to be
exposed to direct Sun have their root
system dry out we tend to find a lot of
biodiversity here and in a lowes or this
near endemic family azo ACA with things
like the jos anthems and live in the
conf items as well and last but not
least on our on our tour of biomes is
the fine boss biome another think the
fine boss biome is what most people
think about when when they talk about
South Africa's the kind of the concept
that comes to mind and what this biome
is kind of looks like is you have lots
of rest eo's lots of grass like plans so
we can kind of see them slide on the
right and then on the left this is kind
of a more typical we see Proteus in the
background but it's it's a shrubby
landscape it never gets so much above 3
meters in height and this is where we
tend to find the highest amount of our
biodiversity and our highest amount of
endemism in our plants just a few more
images of what you may find supports a
large bulb flora as well
on just a few more pictures here for
context you can see in this middle
picture here just the size of this of
this flower head of this Proteus center
Roy DS so I've kind of walked people now
starting from a global scale we step
down to a more a more localized scale by
thinking about biomes and then the the
finest get well pretty much the finest
scale that we're gonna get into here is
vegetation maps and a vegetation map is
a way of defining your flora based based
on more of the species level and more of
the general level and what I kind of
want to point out just here in this
picture is that you know as we look at
the north eastern part of the country
we're still seeing pretty large swatches
of a different color or swathes of germ
color of sorry of solid colors but as we
get down to the western part we just see
it looks like someone took pain just
like smacked it all over place we're
seeing a lot of a lot of different
interactions between all these different
specific vegetation types and so each of
these patches is big enough to be able
to define them broadly by relationships
or likenesses between species in general
but even within that we see that we have
tons of tons of different vegetation
types going on and just a quick thing to
point out here this is pretty much for
looking at the fine boss regions in this
area and this is more of a succulent
crew and these are the main areas the
Western Cape is really the main areas
where we find this these high levels of
speciation occurring within these these
families so just another blow up of this
area we can see that it's it's on the
coast this is an area that primarily
receives winter rainfall and the the
mountain ranges here going both north to
south and east to west are major
definers of this kind of landscape
so the Western Cape as I've probably
hammered into everyone's head at this
point is highly diverse but it's hot
it's not just highly diverse that one of
the things that make it very unique is
you have this high level of endemism and
that's why when you look at the floors
two kingdoms on a broad scale this area
really shows up so one out of five
families twenty percent of the families
in the Western Cape are endemic and on a
species level up to seventy percent of
species are endemic and so what that
means again is plants that are occurring
in just one location but even in most
cases short distance away you won't
you'll find maybe related species but
not the same ones and so again it comes
back to the question of why is this
actually happening and it's not an easy
question to answer sorry I've got ahead
of myself here sorry so the other thing
that defines the Western Cape region
other floor are there other than the
highest levels of endemism is also what
one botanist described as the effect of
excessive speciation and the the most
striking example of this is is the genus
Erica it's known to grow in other parts
of the world as well but in South Africa
out of the 860 species that are known
globally 730 of those occur just within
this one small area and there's other
large examples of this such as the
geraniums that pelargonium or gladiolus
or axcelis other plants that people in
sure may be familiar with having species
numbers that are high above a hundred
just found in the Western Cape so again
the question is why why is this why is
this happening and what are some of the
kind of major drivers that are causing
these this kind of speciation to occur
and there's three or four that I'm we
can present right now the first one as I
pointed out in the picture previously
whether these mountain ranges are a very
important part of the the landscape in
the western cape and the the main
hypothesis or theory here is that these
type of topography complex regions act
as ice as barriers
causing isolation of plants within them
so you may have a plant that is
distributed to a certain extent and then
for from changes in the landscape orders
over time there's not gene flow is not
able to move back and you end up having
speciation events that therefore cause
some of these patterns that we're seeing
a few more images of the topography of
the Western Cape the next is the adipic
the soil properties of the region and
and this has been described as kind of a
mosaic if you looked at a soil survey
map of the Western Cape where you have
in very close proximity to each other
very different soil types and the main
theory here goes is that you're going to
have sister species that are related to
each other but in different soils will
have speciated and formed new ones as
being the next kind of major driver oh
and the thing that I'm sorry to scale
back the other thing about the the the
mountain ranges the other major driver
here that is important is that in these
mountain regions it's considered to have
a long period of climatic stability and
that is a you know one thing you hear
often times cited in and some of the
botany literature is that these long
regions tend to drive speciation as well
and then the the last major major dryer
driver is fire adaptation this is
actually an image that was taken just
last Wednesday in the western cape
region in an area that's known as silver
mine and this is as it was kind of
burning in bringing full force this is a
about a day later looks like absolute
moonscape and like i said this just
happened last week and here's a picture
of the same region when I was out there
in in December so complete
transformation but but most importantly
what the this main kind of the theory
that goes behind this are the plants
abilities and their adaptations to deal
with fire and the main two different
adaptations that you tend to find are in
one hand the reefs prouder is the ones
who are root systems are not completely
destroyed by these by these events but
you have the ability to sprout up once
again or the reefs eaters the plants
that actually need fire to act as
scarification or also just remove
competition to occur and the the idea
here is that you tend to have sister
species that have different fire
adaptations so based on one of the other
you have this speciation events occur so
based on kind of all these different
things I thought maybe South Africa
might be an interesting place to go and
have a look at plants and to study the
flora and and to help out a little bit
so I put an application for the drear to
work at stellenbosch botanical gardens
and just experience this remarkable
flora and so to give people a background
on stellenbosch it is the oldest
university Botanic Garden in Africa who
is originally established in 1902
primarily for as a teaching garden 20
years later and moved to the the
location that it's at now and early on
they had a big focus on succulent plants
as I showed that picture of the postcard
before by Hans Hera he was the first
curator and did a lot of work with this
near endemic family eizo ACA as well as
some these lot of things like like well
which yeah and at stellenbosch that the
garden was originally based off the the
garden design at pad of a the world's
oldest Botanic Garden in Italy but over
time it has changed and stone Bosch is
in a pretty interesting position and
I'll kind of go on I'll talk a little
bit more about this and when I talk
about some of the national botanic
gardens but one of the things that
actually makes them stand out and this
may seem like a funny thing so I just
went on and on about how interesting the
floor of South Africa is is that is that
they actually grow exotic plants they
grow plants that aren't from South
Africa they do grow a lot of plants
they're from South Africa larly for
their conservation program but what this
actually does is it really creates an
opportunity to engage the public and to
draw them into the garden because you
know for you know someone like most
people in the room or myself you go to
South Africa because you want to see the
floor you want to see the fine box you
want to see these these families that
are just totally
you know different than what we're used
to but when you grow up around that you
may not actually realize that what you
have around you is so spectacular unless
you you know have opportunities to
engage with it so one of the unique
places that stellenbosch is actually at
is that they can grow things like
Victoria lilies are strong a load on the
Jade vine or even do the have bonsai
collections which which draw people in
and engage them with the plants in a
landscape in a different way then some
of the other gardens in South Africa can
do they support the educational mission
of the University and they do this
through labs and practicals as well as
collaboration with researchers the
example down here is they stellenbosch
houses the living collection for oxalis
this is one of those general that I
mentioned before has more than 100
species in it and they maintain the
living collection so that the taxonomy
sir working on it and the university can
use it as part of their research and is
a really good relationship for both of
them stellenbosch being a botanic garden
they they keep we have a plant record
system and they use the iris BG system
they're there as of right now some of
the national botanic gardens have also
gotten bored finally but they're
actually stella blushes the first garden
to have a comprehensive plant
record-keeping system and this is one of
those things that um you know most
people kind of maybe not think about
plant records all the time it's one of
those things that makes a botanic garden
different than just a park the fact that
we with that every point that comes into
the collection is is labeled is numbered
we can keep up with the taxonomy we can
take images of it if it's wild collected
will take GPS points and then therefore
you know that when you bring that plant
into your collection it's not just
something interesting to look at but it
also is a representative of that
population from the wild it brings a lot
more value to your collections and also
assists in things like when you're
actively involved in a plant
conservation programs they also run a
plant conservation program as I was just
kind of going on about these are the
three species that they focused on I'm
not going to talking too much detail
about this but this was one of the
primary things that I worked on while I
was down there
this is a deceptive pointed out this is
a dresser arisia it's it's it's a Sun do
they grow around here as well but
there's a lot of diversity down there
and it's one of the biggest in the world
there they're carnivorous plants and
this is a hat for scale but you can just
see the massive length of these leaves
and just a among carnivorous plant
growers this plant has gained a lot of
attention because it is just so so weird
okay and last but not least stellenbosch
botanic garden is another one of its
strengths and other things that makes it
stand out is that it is not part of the
national botanic garden system it's a
small garden there's only eight
permanent staff its affiliation with the
university allows it to take on
initiatives and to kind of be very
nimble and they may not have as much
capital or resources of some of the
bigger gardens to focus on projects but
their small size allows them to make
kind of meaningful small impacts and so
my main goal so I'm just can grab those
well I was in the drear experience was
to go work at stellenbosch McCain garden
but it was to develop my my field botany
skills and some you know I'm in
horticulture department some person may
ask why should he develop why should you
work on field Bonnie and particularly in
Botanic Gardens which I hope to continue
in once I graduate here and have worked
in the past this line between between
botany and horticulture is not not so
well defined a lot of the plants that we
come to appreciate in this day and age
either as ornamental plants obviously at
some place at some point came from the
wild and botanic gardens for a long time
have had a very active role in plant
exploration and also bring plants into
cultivation so then we can use them in
various different types of ways there's
also to help out in plant conservation
program it was also a reciprocal
agreement so in order to give some
expertise and some training to the
garden itself so I helped out and doing
did a lot of work on the plant records
as well as getting in and doing
horticultural work but also did training
I've got a background in Arab oral
culture so doing some work with some of
the staff and learning
to tree climb how to do proper chainsaw
safety use and a couple of these other
kind of skill sets that they didn't
necessarily have down there and then
last but not least was to gain
experience in botanical gardens and not
just at stellenbosch but also with a
number of the other botanic gardens that
I interacted with while I was in South
Africa learning about how they conduct
horticulture and with these special
plants that they grow there and also to
learn about how they manage their
gardens and what their general
approaches and just kind of learning
about the the management of how this is
all done and while I was down there I
also had an opportunity to have a look
around pretty much all the pictures that
we've seen so far our pictures that I've
taken with the exception of a few so
this is just an illustrate this is not
all the places that I want but this is
just illustrations of some of the
natural areas and botanic gardens kind
of across the country that I had
opportunities to visit and interact with
so for the last kind of part of my talk
I'm just going to talk about the state
of biodiversity in South Africa and as
well as a little bit how plant
conservation is actually conducted since
that was the main kind of focus of my
work down there and the state of the
biodiversity in South Africa as I've
kind of described before is very
fascinating but it's also very
challenged one of the challenges that we
have in terms of figuring out how to do
effective plant conservation work is
that we still just don't know people
still just don't know with 30,000
species occurring across all South
Africa people just don't even know what
the full extent of the flora is so the
floor is far from complete new species
are found all the time since 2009
there's been more than 300 new species
described and the rate of discovery
cannot be kept up with the expertise of
taxonomist seeeeee either in South
Africa wart or abroad since there's
experts of these groups kind of all over
the place
many of the threats to biodiversity the
three main biggest ones are ones that we
are familiar with loss of habitat not
alien species species invasion as we can
see up here just marching mr. the
Western Cape region just having Port
Jackson marked cross invasive tree just
march across the landscape as well as a
large one is unethical plant collecting
this isn't a picture from the field this
is actually pictured of kirstenbosch
Botanic Garden where people actually
came in at night and somehow stole
cycads directly out of their collection
which is an amazing feat but really
unfortunate so going to go over some of
the major players in the way that the
way that plant conservation is actually
conducted in South Africa and I
mentioned before the national botanic
gardens are major player in this and
they fall under the purview of what's
known as the south african national
biodiversity institute or sandy and
sandy is a large blanket organization
they are a government organization that
primarily covers all biological research
that goes on across the country so you
could be have entomologist
ornithologists marine biologists
botanists and so on and so on that are
under this since they are very large it
is they have a lot of resources you can
make large impacts but as less time
describing before they may not be the
most nimble and be able to take quick
action which sometimes it's necessary
and San be overseas the national botanic
gardens across all of South Africa there
are there's 10 attempt as just recently
been added and the national botanic
gardens are very interesting
institutions they have a strict mandate
to only grow native plants and this is
kind of getting to the point of what
makes stellenbosch a little bit
different and this is and this is a
wonderful mandate to have because with
so much biodiversity down there it's
important to have folks that are that
are really focusing on working on these
groups that don't grow anywhere else and
also to learn how to display them and
get the the public generally engage with
them so these are mostly pictures all
taken at kirstenbosch lieutenant
and another interesting thing about the
national botanic garden is they all have
contiguous natural areas that are
attached to them so as you can see from
both these pictures here there's
formalized landscapes in the front the
picture on the right is Table Mountain
off into the background that continues
off into Cape Town or a leopard cliff
here on the sorry this up that's on the
right-hand picture the left hand is the
kirstenbosch and these natural areas are
managed there they go on and make sure
invasive plants aren't coming in they do
population counts of species in there
and it's just a continuous part of the
garden in the garden experience which is
a very interesting this is this is a
model that actually Cornell plantations
uses as well they may not be contiguous
but plantations also manages lots of
natural areas and it seems like it makes
sense especially if you want to do plant
conservation work but it's actually
something that's fairly unique there's
not a lot of gardens out there that do
just kind of have this kind of dual role
of natural lands management as well as
cultivated landscapes the national
botanic gardens has the herbarium and
they have departments that are work to
do the work mostly on the systematics
and taxonomy of describe actually
describing the flora in South Africa and
they also like i mentioned have
developed a quarter cultural expertise
in figuring out how to actually grow a
lot of these types of plants and they
they put this out to the general public
in a number of different ways these are
examples of books of how to grow a lot
of these specific jenner or families of
plants that may be unknown to most
people and they've also had the ability
to prioritize learning the horticultural
practices that are necessary to keep
these things live so this is an example
of the succulent collection at crew
national botanic garden and and getting
to talk to the horticulturalist and
people that actually work with these
plants is very very fascinating because
the amount of nuance that they've
developed in how to take care of a lot
of these really interesting taxa is
quite extensive and it's great that they
have it they're putting books out there
they're creating a medium by which they
can express this to the rest of the
world
but the national botanic gardens aren't
the only players in town there also are
other other folks who get involved so
this is an example of a partnership with
industry and a group that I was able to
spend some time with the Capon student
micropropagation they primarily focus on
DISA orchids a genus of orchids these
are a couple pictures of dca uniflora
probably South Africa's most famous
orchid but but they're a private
organization that also does conservation
work so what that means is that they go
out to the field they they're involved
they will do plant surveys like GPS
we're actually they find these plants
they'll pollinate tape capsules program
back figure out how to get them into
into culture grow them on and then
they'll do different things with them
depending on what species they are if
there's a mental interest in them to
figure out ways to continue these these
plants in culture and then send them
internationally abroad to to make some
money for the organization but then they
also will go back out and do replant
reintroductions Cape instituted
micropropagation also worked with
stellenbosch and on d sub r beta which
is one of them has one of the smallest
populations of any decent and they're
doing repopulation 'he's using these
kind of methods and protocols you also
tend to find conservation being
conducted in places like private gardens
in lots of in the part of South Africa
that I was in there's lots of estates
and and vineyards that are kind of a
major part of the horticultural trade in
general but one of the interesting
partnerships that you'll find is is some
of these gardens actually being active
in plant conservation and so the example
of this is the silver tree here on the
right leucadendron argentia was known to
be kind of have one main population on
Table Mountain it over the years this
kind of declined kirstenbosch has been
active in maintaining that but the only
other known population a disjunct
population was also found and these
aren't these aren't the best pictures
but this is very close to stellenbosch
the town that i was in these mountain
ranges than in the background this the
Rustenburg wine estate goes pretty much
right up to this mountain slope
and on these slopes they found a second
population of this leucadendron
argenteum and not because they have to
because they want to and they're
interested in conservation they actually
go out there a movement basic plants and
they monitor these populations and try
to keep them striped thriving as well
there's also a big citizen science
initiative and people who are just
generally interested in plant
conservation in South Africa and this is
one organized example of that known as
crew custodians of the rare and
endangered wildflowers and these are
folks who are they're mostly retired but
they're a volunteer group that weld its
base by region they'll identify natural
areas within their region that um
haven't been surveyed and look
coordinate with Sam be and the go out
and I'll actually do these surveys where
they actually see what's going on out
there lookee population counts and then
I'll submit that so that it can be used
for for for consensus across the whole
country another example this is a
program known as I spot I spot as an
application you can get for your phone
and what it is is if you are out
botanizing doesn't matter if you're just
walking around you're on your you're
farming on your land and you see a plant
that you don't know is I'm interest to
you you can take a picture of it you can
post it up on I spot either attempted
identify yourself or it will alert
experts and they'll come in and take a
look at these plants and identify them
and this is a great way of kind of you
know doing quick surveying on the ground
but what's been interesting about it is
that as more and more people have been
using this program that there's actually
been a whole handful of species that
have actually been discovered because of
this process and this is an example of
one that we saw I saw one of the flower
shows where folks actually someone just
took a picture of this and went out to
the expert they didn't know what it is
they came and they did the field work
they were able to describe it find it
define it and therefore was introduced
as a new species
so kind of getting towards the end of
the talk here well why does it all
matter we've described how there's so
much biodiversity in South Africa and a
lot of it is a kind of under threat and
and this is the same challenge that
plant conservation is focus have
everywhere in South Africa emit self
about roughly twenty-five percent of the
flora is either threatened or of
conservation concern but the kind of
point I want to make here is that you
know we all know that plant conservation
or any kind of conservation is a very
important activity to undertake and
instead of focusing on what the sheer
numbers are here through the main of the
examples that I've shared with you
before I think more of the point is that
is that there's a lot of interested
parties and interesting collaborations
that are being conducted that really
really look to address these problems on
multiple levels and I think that was a
really interesting and powerful finding
for me to have and just just in general
it's not just that in on a global
perspective that the plants that we all
you know are threatened or in peril but
but there's also been a restriction in
in the education of how to actually you
know conduct some of us work so these
are two articles that came out just this
last week in popular media one is
talking about it's talking about
collections specifically and the value
that those hold and the other one is
talking about field biology skills and
how fewer and fewer folks are actually
being trained in these field so we have
is you know we have challenges in
conservation not just on the plant side
but also in our education system and I
think my last kind of point is that is
that even though again we have these
challenges I think it's more of a point
of optimism that we still have places
like educational institutions
universities and botanic gardens which
are able to pull all this information
together and since I've been giving this
perspective from the side of Botanic
Gardens these institutions really stand
out as being places that can do this
work not only on a theoretical level but
actually can get out there and do the
applied work and they can bring all
their resources they have to bear to to
this mission so not
just monitoring these plants in the
population and in the wild and
monitoring populations but actually
developing quarter cultural protocols
how to do institue an ex situ
conservation how to document the floor
of our world and follow up with the kind
of research that is is important to
allow plant conservation to happen and
so that's kind of it so with that I'd
like to thank the horticulture section
or department and the drear committee
for allowing me to have this kind of
experience there's a lot of direction
this talk could have gone and win a lot
of different ways anyway so if you have
questions please please feel free to
come up it docked me about it I want to
thank stellenbosch botanic garden in the
University and in particular Martin
Smith the curator at stellenbosch and
his wife mike is smitten their child
aria and thanks for one who followed my
blog and just showing up today and with
that
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu